[Music]
[Applause]
get big fast
the mantra of amazon.com and its
boisterous founder
jeff bezos from the moment i got there
the feeling was that you just pressed
down on the accelerator harder and
harder
the audacious entrepreneur rewrote the
rules of retail
there really was this sense of urgency
around this
internet land grab that was taking place
you know how do we establish the amazon
brand
his strategy didn't always pay off even
after amazon went public people looked
at the financials and said
this company's not going to make it
amazon.com
was actually profitable in december
1995. it must have been for
oh about one hour with a series of sly
moves
jeff bezos built and rebuilt amazon.com
if you ask a question that jeff doesn't
feel like is something they want to go
into
the answer you get's going to be the
laugh
[Laughter]
and he's laughing all the way to the
bank
[Music]
you can buy anything at amazon.com from
books
music shoes and clothing to a battle
tank
or a tiki hut amazon is the most
successful online retailer in the world
and still run by the man who created it
back in 1994
jeff bezos jeff seemed to realize
that being the singular place where a
consumer can find and buy virtually
anything that's available in the retail
market
was a critical part of the company's
growth strategy
the public image of jeff bezos is of a
superhero entrepreneur and he is that
if you look at his life from the very
beginning he's taken risks and he's
solved problems and he's created
billions of dollars wealth
bezos is more guarded than his outgoing
public persona
and declined to participate in this
program
jeffrey preston bezos was born in
albuquerque new mexico
on january 12 1964 to jackie guys
a 17 year old high school student
guys divorced his biological father and
married miguel
bezos a cuban immigrant and petroleum
engineer for exxon
miguel adopted four-year-old bezos in
1968
bezos described his early computer
experience in a 2001 interview with the
academy of achievement
there was a company in houston that had
loaned
excess mainframe computer time to this
little elementary school
none of the teachers knew how to operate
this computer nobody did but there was a
stack of manuals and
me and a couple of other kids stayed
after class and learned how
to program this thing as a teen bezos
embarked on his first serious
entrepreneurial effort a summer camp
based out of his house with an emphasis
on science and literature
five students signed up at 150 a pop
1986 he graduated from princeton
university
summa [ __ ] laude with degrees in
electrical engineering
and computer science nicholas carlson is
deputy editor at businessinsider.com
and has covered amazon for six years
jeff bezos was actually recruited into a
hedge fund named de shaw
and he didn't want to work in finance he
actually wanted to work in computer
programming
but d e shaw is a computer programmer
and the hedge fund is sort of built
around
algorithms and the type of technology
that bezos is interested in
it wasn't the only thing he found
interesting he came upon
a statistic that just astounded him he
saw that the internet was growing at
2 300 per year and he just became
obsessed with this number
studying the top 20 mail-order
businesses bezos saw an opportunity
online chris anderson is the former
editor-in-chief
for wired magazine he could see that
there was this technological
tsunami that was arriving that was going
to disintermediate
it was going to create new distribution
channels reset economics
change the way we bought and sold and
the question was which domain shall we
apply it to
the answer was books a commodity for
which no comprehensive catalog
existed in july 1994
he quit his secure wall street job to
pursue his dream
to create one of the world's first
online bookstores
his first investors his parents who he
talked about with the academy of
achievement
my dad's first question was what's the
internet okay so this he wasn't making
a bet on this company or this concept
he was making a bet on his son in the
summer of 1994
jeff bezos and his wife mackenzie headed
to washington state
armed with three hundred thousand
dollars from his parents entrepreneur
and technology expert esther dyson
is chairman of the investment firm
adventure holdings
you now have a lot of people leaving
wall street to go and try and do
startups but jeff was different he had a
really solid
business wall street background and then
he created something amazing
bezos and his wife settled in bellevue
washington
and hired two programmers to write the
code
bezos related the story in a speech at
lake forest college in 1998.
i found a house that could serve as the
first business and it had a garage and
seemed the right thing to do since
there's a history of startups and
garages
this wasn't fully legitimate because it
was a converted enclosed garage but i
considered it somewhat legitimate
because it wasn't insulated those were
not
impressive offices he dubbed the company
amazon
after the seemingly endless south
american river with its countless
tributaries
on july 16 1995 amazon.com opened its
virtual doors to the public
james marcus was employee number 55.
marcus was hired to write book reviews
for the site that was nothing more than
a list of titles
when i checked out their site to see if
this was a place where i might want to
work
i discovered it was quite rudimentary
actually there was
a front page with an eclectic mixture of
books but
the most notable thing was that there
was a huge catalog of probably several
hundred thousand books at the time
but there was no content in that catalog
the fledgling amazon.com had no
advertising budget initial sales were
generated solely by word of mouth
heath terry is a managing director at
goldman sachs
there was a lot different about amazon
really from the beginning you know they
weren't in silicon valley they were in
seattle
they weren't really into the whole hype
of the bubble they weren't putting out
press releases every single day
the site caught on within a month books
had been sold to customers in all 50
states
and 45 other countries what was
different about amazon was that
jeff ran it right he was organized he
understood distribution
he understood how to motivate people to
buy he just
he did things with great attention to
detail
bezos goal for growing the company could
be summed up in a simple line
get big fast was both a mantra and very
much a strategic decision on jeff's part
everything had to be on steroids all
growth had to be on steroids
eric best was manager of business
development at amazon from 1999
to 2001. there really was this sense of
urgency around
capturing ecommerce market share this
internet land grab that was taking place
you know how do we establish the amazon
brand and grow the overall business
at the expense of competitors and within
a very time-bound window
the strategy paid off big time by the
end of 1996
the company reached 15.7 million dollars
in sales
the gains were boosted by amazon's
ability to offer tax-free
shopping to most online consumers what
makes us different is
vast selection convenience we deliver
right to the desktop
and also the fact that we're the
broadest discounters in the world we
discount over 300 000 titles basically
the best-selling titles that's twice as
many titles as the largest
physical bookstore even offers
[Music]
but early investors were frustrated the
surge in sales came without profits
while amazon spent millions developing
software and expanding its business
you know there was a lot of risk that
was taken on by the company during those
early days
and i think there was a lot of
speculation around whether or not that
was the right thing to do
it's easy now to look back and say of
course amazon
uh needed that capital and they needed
to invest at the rate that they did in
order to achieve the scale that they now
have
that was not always clear from day one
what was clear was that bezos was
unstoppable
he kept up the pace and powered ahead
for amazon's ipo
the idea was that you could not rest on
your laurels for one moment
and that you just had to keep innovating
all the time and staying out of the
competition all the time and never have
even a millisecond of complacency
[Music]
on may 15 1997 the stock began trading
on the nasdaq stock market
at 29.25 a share nearly 12
higher than its offering price the day
of the actual ipo was a very big deal
there were you know parties all over the
company and
jeff addressed us you know over the
speaker phone from new york
i mean jeff was telling us on the phone
you know we've made history today you
have all made history today
it was pretty damn exciting but despite
the well-received ipo
tech analysts still offered a dollar
assessment of the company tim o'reilly
is founder and ceo of o'reilly media
most people remember the business
stories that amazon was going to be
toast
people were scrutinizing their
financials they were saying this company
will never be profitable
or there were a lot of naysayers the
company's engineers were hard at work
updating the site introducing features
like one-click shopping
by the end of 1997 the value of amazon
stock
nearly tripled jeff would say to us do
not pay attention to the stock price
he was very confident that in the long
run it would go up and up and up
but felt it was very dangerous to look
at it in the short run
amazon continued their frantic expansion
hiring more than 7
000 employees and beefing up their
product line
you know we just heard talk about
virtually everything and anything we
could sell groceries
health care cell phone plans and cell
phones magazines and then eventually you
know hardware garden hoses and toys
the expanded product line and high
volume sales paid off for both
amazon.com and bezos
on december 20th 1999 he was anointed
time magazine's person of the year made
my mom
cry and uh you know parents are always
proud and that feels great
it was the the ultimate legitimization
of his sort of starry-eyed dream of
conquering the world through e-commerce
like you flip to the inside of the
magazine there's jeff dressed as indiana
jones swinging on a vine
it was kind of making him into an
american folk hero in a way it's like
you suddenly like paul bunyan was in the
office down the hall from you
bezos was at the top of his game but an
industry-wide disaster
was right around the corner by the late
90s
amazon.com was an online juggernaut
but in 2000 the dot-com bubble burst
stock prices slumped and jeff bezos was
forced to take drastic measures
there were at least two waves of layoffs
and as is usually the case with these
things you don't know who's going to go
you kind of cower in your office
and wait for the hr person to you know
summon you with a finger
and it feels bad to see your colleagues
go in the context of the slowing economy
and the uh the the deep slowing and
consumer confidence
this was the only prudent decision that
we could make
by september 2001 the company's stock
hit an all-time low
and bottomed out at five dollars and
ninety seven cents a share
from poster child to whipping boy in
nanoseconds it's not the kind of stock
that you can own
and sleep well if you're a small
investor and i think by the way that's
true of all
internet stocks the advantage that
amazon had
was they had built this war chest so to
speak
on their their balance sheet of cash to
to fund them through all this
jeff bezos made a lot of large bets and
not all of them paid off
the company didn't profit for many years
in the beginning
the reason jeff bezos got away with that
and benefited long term is because he
was always
very direct with employees and
stakeholders in the company
at long last by january 2002
those bets began to pay off amazon's
stock price rebounded
and bezos company did something it
hadn't done in seven years
posted a profit the best thing could say
about him is that he was unwavering in
his confidence
he could see the bigger picture and he
knew that the skeptics were
short-termers they were not seeing the
big picture and he stuck to the vision
once the bubble burst the investors
patience
for companies saying we're going to make
big investments in building out a
dot-com side to our business
was very very thin and so amazon took
advantage of that and started partnering
with
target and toys r us and the gap and
other traditional retailers
the dot com retail giant joined forces
with more than 400 companies
but not all retailers were willing
partners i do know of a number of cases
in which
he has acquired companies in order to
take out competitors
potential future competitors rather than
because he actually wants
that business to continue with his
company back on track
bezos switched gears and increased his
focus on a much different passion
on march 6 2003 he charted a helicopter
to scout property in a remote
region of southwest texas he was looking
to buy up ranches
for a venture he had started in 2000
called
blue origin blue origin is a technology
company
whose purpose was to develop vertical
takeoff and vertical landing rockets
for human space travel the trip
was nearly a disaster shortly after
takeoff
the helicopter flipped and landed in a
riverbed
in 2003 jeff bezos almost died in a
helicopter crash
it's sort of a pattern where he can go
through something difficult like a
dot-com crash be philosophical about it
laugh it off with his big famous laugh
unlike space exploration ventures bank
rolled by private backers including elon
musk richard branson and john carmack
bezos is obsessive about keeping his
efforts at blue origin
secret for a variety of reasons it's
pretty secretive
and i think actually from the point of
view of the space industry that's sort
of a pity
what makes a good market is when you
have
a bunch of competitors openly competing
and they try and position themselves
against one another
and the market's visible they compete
for money they compete for people and so
forth
after six years of working behind closed
doors and locked gates
blue origin's odd-looking test rocket
blasted off
[Applause]
bezos was also set to launch on another
revolutionary effort
this one closer to home this is an
opportunity to
hugely expand the book industry expand
pricing expand the definition of what a
book can be
but it required someone with sufficient
clout to do that end-to-end hardware
software web
integration and only amazon was in a
position
to do that on november 19 2007
jeff bezos took to the charlie rose show
to announce the release of a
groundbreaking new product
here in my hands is what we're talking
about
it is called the kindle tell me when you
first had the idea
that this might be possible what we
realized at the time
was that there were a few technologies
that were sort of converging
that we could combine together at the
right recipe
and make something that would be what we
hoped would be transformative
in the world of electronic reading the
kindle
was an instant hit amazon put this
device out there that
takes away so many of the aesthetic
pleasures that people take in books you
know you can't smell the pages anymore
dog ear the books but it turns out book
lovers who are all these people that
feared and load this thing now they love
the kindle
the 399 dollar e-reader sold out
nationwide in just
five and a half hours the number of
kindles sold however remains a closely
guarded secret
a company spokesman said that they
choose not to disclose the number
jane friedman is former ceo of
harpercollins and co-founder
of open road integrated media no one
today
knows how many kindles there really are
out there
it's a guessing game we know that there
are millions but how many millions
but it's strategic for amazon obviously
because that's what they do they keep a
lot of information close to the vest
but publishers saw the kindle as an
industry killer
there will be a real blood on the tracks
of publishing in the next few years
because publishers did not wake up soon
enough to the fact that amazon
was a competitor
[Music]
while the kindle was making serious
waves in the e-book marketplace
amazon was preparing to make its largest
corporate acquisition to date
tony shea is ceo of zappos.com america's
leading online shoe retailer
when i first met jeff bezos in 2004 he
had
contacted us and said they were
interested in
possibly acquiring zappos at the time we
said we weren't interested
because zappos would kind of lose its
identity
shea was hesitant to sell to amazon they
contacted us again and said they were
willing to consider a different scenario
where
we could remain independent and we
started realizing
wow they might actually be really great
partners
amazon purchased the hot online shoe
retailer in the summer of 2009
zappos investors received 10 million
amazon shares
worth about 1.2 billion dollars at the
time the deal closed
they got stock which at this point is
better than cash and what this kind of
shows is that jeff bezos and amazon is
someone who
yes he can steamroll the competition
when he needs to but he's also
willing to play ball and negotiate and
get what he wants
but make everybody wealthier in the
process the shoe
fit but his cash cow the kindle was
about to get some very serious
competition
from a tech giant and we call it
the ipad on january 27
2010 apple launched the ipad
also designed for use as an electronic
reading device
bezos responded aggressively by cutting
costs
and adding new features to his e-reader
one thing that bezos has always been
comfortable doing running
amazon is playing with very tight
margins
so when you see the kindle lowering in
price what you're seeing
is bezos recognizing what the real
long-term gain here for amazon is
to be the place where everyone buys all
of their ebooks
and the kindle is just how they get them
the phenomenal growth of the e-book
market
devastated bricks and mortar stores
amazon came on the scene and became a
competitor
to the bricks and mortar retailers and
they were the e-tailer everybody was
coexisting
in fact borders and it may have been
their downfall but borders did all of
their digital
their digital selling through amazon had
borders established its
own presence it might have been a very
different situation today
according to the authors guild amazon
had been buying books from publishers at
12 to 13
wholesale and selling them as kindle
books for 9.99
taking a loss each time best-selling
author
john grisham railed against amazon's
pricing model
we're going to get to a point if a book
is worth ten dollars okay
whether it's a discounted hardback at
amazon or an e-book sold by
amazon for the kindle if we're ten
dollars okay then suddenly the whole
industry is going to change you're going
to lose publishers you're going to lose
bookstores
others saw opportunity you look at all
of the authors that have been
kind of empowered by kendall to develop
a direct consumer relationship that they
never had before and i think that's
where amazon
is able to come out a winner
in all of this by building this bridge
between
authors and their readers that in the
past has never really existed
borders books filed for bankruptcy and
barnes noble
the largest bookstore chain has been
struggling
in 2011 amazon.com stepped beyond the
retail sales market
and into the video streaming ring going
head-to-head
with netflix andrew wallenstein is a tv
editor for variety magazine i think if
you're netflix you're looking at amazon
and really sizing them up as a
competitor
amazon has a lot of traction online
they've got deep pockets to buy just as
much content
they're at the very beginning of this
kind of effort but in time amazon could
grow to be just as big as netflix
the e-commerce retail giant is also
fending off growing efforts to put an
end to its untaxed online sales
several states now require amazon to
charge local sales tax
but bezos remains cool under fire and
unfazed he continues to forge ahead jeff
bezos has his fingers in everybody's pie
he's got video streaming which competes
with netflix
he's doing music now which competes with
apple and itunes
he's even selling android apps in an
amazon.com
app store that goes right after google's
marketplace
if he sees something where amazon can
make a little piece of money
and help its margins which are you know
so thin he'll go for it
going forward has gotten him this far
his space
project is going even farther in april
2011
nasa awarded blue origin 22 million
dollars to continue developing its space
vehicle design
he was listed by bloomberg as the 20th
richest person in the world
with a net worth estimated at 25 billion
dollars
amazon.com remains the world's largest
online retailer he's not just a
visionary with visions he's an architect
with blueprints
and some notion of how to make things
work he thinks very carefully about
design and structure and operations
and that's what turns a visionary into
somebody who actually accomplishes
something
he could have sold amazon to barnes
noble or probably to some other
booksellers and walked away with many
millions of dollars like in his early
30s
since then he just keeps on coming up
with really good ideas
he's not the hard charging
going to take no prisoners type ceo
he's somebody that has his vision for
how he wants to build this company
and is able to surround himself by
people that buy into that i think
ultimately that's one of the reasons
that he's been as successful as he has
[Music]
you